so the pill so you get like a couple of  them right  um and the like first it wasn't even  like I felt something was stuck so I had  to go go back there and they had to like  take out with them  also called them  four soaps yeah yeah that was my first  um abortion and I had a second one and  um it was it was a pill and you know and  um I decided to go ahead and it was the  worst experience ever because they they  did not inform me that a whole child  would come out of there you know and I  would think it would be in part so I  wouldn't see it you know and it was a  full little child it was the size of my  palm but it was such a horrible  experience you know and I've seen it I  I've seen it